this program is brought to you by Emory
University high if you have the time I'd
like to read a letter dear mr. Roberto
si goetta my name is John Thomas I'm a
student graduating in the class of 2011
at your business school see we never met
because while you were running a
billion-dollar corporation I was in
third grade I was learning
multiplication tables and trying to
convince a girl by the name of Melissa
Hill to be my Valentine but still I'm
honored I got to go to your school I'm
honored I get to be on a stage the
people such as this and part of that
comes I want to say thank you the
opportunity to go into classrooms with
teachers that demand and critique more
than you would ever think was possible
of yourself and out of it comes
excellence and sometimes we get to do it
too we have conversations with each
other with their professors where we
stand there and we ask more of business
leaders executives and everyone in an
attempt to raise that level of
excellence but with that I don't have a
question for you and with that I'd like
to look for your legacy for advice
you see we're graduating now we're
entering the real world and as I've been
told many times the real world is not
like college see I've been told again
we're afforded idealism as college
students because we don't know the
brutality of what could lay ahead we
don't know what's actually out there I
heard it once explained by a professor
in college you taught a lesson and then
given an exam in the real world you're
given an exam and then taught a lesson
there will be no extra credit there will
be no discussion of I got a B+ can I get
20 - none of that happens but still as
part of this class I know we're excited
for the opportunity and the adventure
that holds and with that one of the
quotes that the Dean spoke about earlier
that you have written on the walls I've
seen it since my sophomore year
it says the cynics of the world will
tell you the good you do today will be
forgotten tomorrow do it anyway
the cynics of the world will tell you
the good you do today will be forgotten
tomorrow do it anyway
as a sophomore not really knowing what I
was doing still don't really know
honesty I looked at that and I thought
okay what is that is that join a
non-profit is that go out and help with
humanitarian aid devote myself to
something greater well I think that
quote is all about those things I think
it's something more it's a business
principle because what it to its core is
asking why not creating students and
professors alike that always ask why not
pushing progress where others only see
standards demanding more of oneself in a
pursuit of excellence see it's something
when I started to think about this I
recognized I've been doing this since I
was a kid I'd go see movies with my
parents I'd ask them to explain words
and questions why the world sees it this
way that childlike innocence begs the
question why not and it's something that
we can tend to get stuck in our own
situation in our own rut and miss out on
the big picture of asking why not it's
really an exciting thing from all the
classes for all the students you've seen
up here before entrepreneurship classes
where you're challenged to find areas to
see potential and ask why not why can't
I do it differently there finance
financial investing long-term growth
value strategies often tend to look at
companies that others might have
overlooked and asked why not consulting
your paid to ask why not and give them
the answer like that's essentially what
it is
marketing you're taught to tell people
here's why not pick this one not this
one why not so sir
I want to thank you when I look to your
legacy I want to thank you for the
students
you created a class that asks why not
not in the pursuit of controversy not to
make some small and simple raise of
issue always in a pursuit of excellence
that's something we've learned since our
beginning times here and when we enter a
real world that's less forgiving and
without extra credit we will always have
that we will always be able to stand
there and make it our own and say why
not leave our mark shape and evolve
what's to come
so again I just want to say thanks I've
loved it here I really have learned a
lot it's true we've been given tools
such as Excel to where I don't really
need my multiplication tables anymore
but still what characterizes this class
and the others to follow is our ability
to ask why not so I challenge 2011
graduating seniors always ask that you
may always it won't always work out but
it will give you something to make it
your own even when you feel lost thanks
for listening
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University